digamos que tenemos un polinomio p de x
que podemos factorizar para ponerlo de
la forma x menos 1 x x + 2 x x menos 3 x
x + 4
lo que nos interesa aquí son los ceros
de este polinomio y se pueden preguntar
qué son los ceros de un polinomio pues
son los valores de x que van a hacer que
este polinomio sea igual a 0 otra forma
de pensar en esto es para cuáles valores
de x
pd x va a ser igual a 0 y otra forma de
pensar en esto es para que valores de x
esta expresión va a ser igual a 0 para
que valores de x va a ser x 1 x x + 2 x
x menos 3 x x + 4 igual a 0
los invito a que pausa en el vídeo y
reflexionan sobre esto antes de que lo
resolvamos juntos el punto importante
aquí es darnos cuenta de que si tenemos
el producto de varias expresiones con
que cualquiera de estas expresiones sea
igual a cero no importa qué valor tengan
las otras todo
esto va a ser cero debido a que 0
multiplicado por cualquier cosa va a ser
igual a 0 el término sofisticado para
esto es la propiedad 0 del producto pero
todo lo que dices oye si puedes
encontrar un valor de x que haga que
cualquiera de estas expresiones sea
igual a 0 ese valor hará que toda la
expresión sea igual a 0 así que los
ceros de este polinomio serán los
valores de x que hagan que x menos 1 sea
igual a 0 y ya sabemos cuál valor va a
hacer que ocurra si x es igual a 1 si
sumamos 1 en ambos lados x es igual a 1
por lo que x igual a 1 va a ser un 0 de
este polinomio otra forma de expresar
esto es que puede uno cuando x es igual
a 1 todo el polinomio va a ser igual a 0
como sé eso porque si pongo un 1 aquí
esta expresión de x menos 1 va a ser
igual a cero y 0 x cualquier cosa va a
ser igual a 0
y siguiendo la misma idea podemos
encontrar cuáles son los otros ceros qué
valor hace que esta parte sea igual a
cero qué valor de x hace que x + 2 sea
igual a cero pues x igual a menos 2 x
igual a menos 2 hace que x + 2 sea igual
a 0 así que x igual a menos 2 va a ser
otro cero de este polinomio y podemos
continuar que hace que x menos tres sea
igual a cero pues cuando x es igual a 3
eso hará que x menos 3 sea igual a 0 lo
que a su vez hará que toda esta
expresión sea igual a 0 y por último
pero no menos importante que hará que x
4 sea igual a cero pues x igual a menos
4 es así como hemos encontrado 40 de
este polinomio cuando x es igual a 1 el
polinomio es igual a cero cuando x es
igual a menos 2 el polinomio es igual a
cero cuando x es igual a 3 el polinomio
es igual a 0 y cuando x es igual a menos
el polinomio es igual a cero algo
interesante sobre los ceros de un
polinomio es que podemos usarlos para
comenzar a darnos una idea de cómo luce
su gráfica por ejemplo sabemos que este
polinomio va a ser igual a 0 en estos
ceros
vamos a hacer una gráfica muy rápida
este es el eje x este lg y y en x igual
a 1 mejor primero dibujo las escalas 1 2
3 y 4 y tenemos menos 1 - 2 - 3 y menos
4 sabemos que este polinomio pd x va a
ser igual a cero cuando x sea igual a 1
intersec a al eje x aquí va a ser igual
a cero cuando x sea igual a menos 2
justo acá cuando x es igual a 3 que es
aquí y cuando x es igual a menos 4 con
estos valores no sabemos cómo es
exactamente la gráfica podemos calcular
algunos valores en ambos lados para
saber si está por arriba o por d
del eje x para valores de x menores al
menos 4 etcétera podemos tratar de hacer
varias cosas pero sabemos con certeza
que intersecta al eje x en todos estos
puntos puede lucir algo así puede verse
así no lo sabremos sin hacer más
cálculos yo me tomé un tiempo y use una
aplicación para graficar este polinomio
y como ven luce exactamente como
esperaríamos la gráfica de este
polinomio intersec a al eje x cuando x
es igual a menos 4 vamos a usar los
respectivos colores cuando x es igual a
menos 4 que es este cero de aquí cuando
x es igual a menos 2 que es este 0 de
acá x igual a 1 justo aquí y también
cuando x es igual a 3 por acá
en próximos vídeos estudiaremos esto con
más detalle